so Prime Minister you just described
labour doing a deal that it says it
doesn't want to do as a prospect made in
hell that will going up from chaos and
ruin how far we're going to get on the
on the on the fee ramat well I think it
is very very worrying because we haven't
had in our recent history an example of
a Nationalist Party but one part of the
United Kingdom playing a part in the
government of the whole of the United
Kingdom saying very frankly I will make
ed Miliband Prime Minister I'll write
the first budget you can't have Trident
submarines unless you you know we're
going to cut all these other aspects of
Defense hs2 won't be built in the way
that all the parties united kingdom up
to now have agreed that's only in 24
hours those three examples I've just
given you that I think calling that a
chilling prospect or a frightening
prospect I think that is not an
understatement not an overstatement I'm
afraid but the latent labor have won't
sign up to any of those policy position
will sign up to a coalition but labour
have been asked in a dozens of times do
you rule out having any formal
arrangement with the SMP and they won't
answer the question in again in the last
24 hours Andy Burnham health speech LOL
secretary Angela Eagle shadow leader of
the House of Commons saying well let's
wait and see and I'm sure we'll talk to
everybody and perhaps there are things
we can do together I think genuinely
this is a very frightening prospect the
SNP love Nicola Sturgeon ism
deeply plausible politician and speaks
very clearly and all the rest of it
she's only got one major aim in life and
that is to break up the United Kingdom
these separatists they're not interested
in making the Westminster Parliament
stronger we ask yourself this question
does Nicola Sturgeon at the end of five
years want people to look back and go
well that was a good government in
Westminster the Westminster Parliament
working well for me no of course not
choose to break up the Westminster
Parliament and break up our country but
that's just minority government labour
have said nothing other than if if the
parliamentary arithmetic falls like that
they'd have to consider the views of all
the minority parties that's just how it
would they they should rule they should
do what I'm doing which is to rule out
any form of arrangement with the SAS
physically SNP MPs going through the
division are physically stop them voting
but you can stop any form of
conversation or agreement or
understanding with them because there is
no understanding you can reach with a
group of people that want to break up
your kind of hungry hang on though when
you a conservative leader in 2007 you
must have green lighted Annabel Goldie
supporting the SNP in a minority
government in holy but there's a world
of difference because of course in the
Holyrood Parliament that is a parliament
that the SNP thinks ought to exist did
you give permission for that arranged I
talked to animal gold or get all those
and you said yes we will have
conservatives I'm a minority as a SNP
there's a huge difference because the
Hollywood Parliament is something the
SNP believe it
right the Westminster Parliament they
think should be abolished they think the
United Kingdom shouldn't exist so this
is not a group of friendly people coming
to come coming down to Westminster with
some good ideas for how to run Britain
all they want to do is to create a set
of circumstances where the breakup of
our country becomes more likely you
could have pulled the plug on the Alex
Salmond government in Scotland back in
08 09 when he was struggling to pass the
budget but you allowed your Scottish
leadership to continue there's a world
of difference wouldn't have he hit won't
even had it refer what there's a world
of difference between what happens in
Holyrood a parliament that the SNP
believe in and what happens in
Westminster Parliament than the SMP
believe can I take you back to September
the 19th it's a 7am when you made that
speech after the referendum at 5am
Alistair Darling calls you and says do
not do not do this you're letting Alex
Salmond back in the front door isn't the
truth you're saying that there are
threats from labor and the SNP but your
actions at 7am let the SNB back in the
game when they find defeat I don't
accept that for a moment the SMP the
proposition of separation was defeated
and that remains the case but as Prime
Minister I think is right to speak for
the whole of the United Kingdom and I
think it's quite right that just as
we've delivered on Scottish devolution
we're going to deliver more on Welsh
devolution we've maintained that and
actually strengthened the institutions
in Northern Ireland so it's time for the
English voice to be heard as well and
stoking up English lessons no not at all
and i don't think the English are
nationalistic at all
but what I think people in England want
to know is just as there is the ability
of Scottish MPs now to set their own
effectiveness at their own income tax
rate so English MPs and the Westminster
Parliament should be able to do the same
thing so unbelievably reasonable
proposition I mean ask yourself this
question why is it the dead Miliband is
happy to work with me on Scottish
devolution Welsh devolution Northern
Irish Division who when he comes to
England he won't even have that
conversation so frightened is he off of
this issue which i think is completely
wrong hey your speech today talks about
this Carlile principal it seems to be in
the back of your mind and if you look at
the work the Scottish conservatives
dudes that there is a vein of thought
that sees Britain becoming a bit more
federal August could you imagine a
federalized you're going about the
following you I don't think of all sort
of federal state works because when you
look at the united kingdom england is so
much bigger than the other part I think
you'll be very unbalanced federal
systems I think what we have to do is to
make devolution work better in the
nations of our United Kingdom so
Scottish and Welsh parliaments in my
view that should have these tax raising
powers so they're not just organizations
for spending money they got
responsibility for raising it and then
in England I think what we need is some
the ability for English MPs to have the
decisive say over those matters that
affect England then I think it'll so
this you could settle down we haven't
reached a resting place on this issue
and that's what I badly want us to reach
so you were talking a good life at the
manifesto launched last week and now we
have images of health
SNP supported like while you were at the
rally I was just speaking out the first
half of which was very clear about the
positive message about a plan that's
working 2 million more people in work
750 15 hours more businesses a strongly
growing economy I mean there's an
incredibly positive message and positive
offer from the Conservative Party but I
don't hide from people the fact that
there is a choice all of this is put at
risk I had been around in the SNP as out
of our own I mean Nicola Sturgeon ski
asked in our manifesto today is an
additional one hundred and forty eight
billion pounds of borrowing and don't
tell me that's not important that is a
massive statement of intent by a party
that thinks it could hold you know ed
Miliband's feet to the fire in
government to be clear though you're
saying that this is relevant because
labour can't win a majority but you
don't know that so you'll be bigger well
the figures have you become a supposed
friend what would I haven't but all the
safale gist sino and indeed every other
it points out that it's almost
impossible for head middle man now to
win an overall majority given them goes
to the consumer so that's not the case
we are 23 seats short of a majority so
if we hold the seats we have and win 23
more see it's perfectly possible in our
system and then we'd have a majority
respectfully you haven't had a poll
showing a seven percent lead since
they're spending review of 2010 but we
add a pole with a six percent lead last
week for instance so anyway the only
poll accounts is on polling day but look
that the maths of the election is quite
clear is important fact because we're 23
seats shorts I want people to feel
empowered that if they want to continue
with the plan if they want the two
million more jobs if they want the plans
in our manifesto the right to buy your
house more child care then they can vote
for those things knowing we're in 23
seats short of delivering those things
and stopping
the nightmare of a SNP miliband
concoction let's talk about the writer
by then you reheated that as a Newton's
went over there this is a massive policy
that would give you know millions of
people the right to do what I suspect
you've already done by a row know so do
you think when you look at the policy
from 2012 that you already announced and
even from the 1980s a feature of the
record of that policy is that you have
not replaced the social houses so it's
easier to say you will not with this and
they'll be less than I was it takes time
to replace you to get the receipt from
the house you sell and you then need to
spend that money in the same area
building a new house and that takes time
with the ambition of one-to-one
replacement is absolutely there and the
difference in advantage with this policy
because we're saying that local councils
should sell off the most expensive
properties when they become vacant some
properties in london council robbed is
worth a million pounds with that money
you could build you know eight flats for
people on warehousing waiting this some
of the poorest people in our country
who'd love to be housed in the way that
they're not today it just rather looks
that you have this long-term economic
plan but just before election a series
of shorts and giveaways on housing on
pensioner bonds but I don't I don't
accept that at all what is short term
about the right to buy the right away
your council house was always short term
policy it was a long term fundamental
change in our country that gave millions
of people who didn't have an asset the
chance to buy and own a home of their
own I feel that deeply as it
conservative that's something I want to
see more of in our country pension of
bonds it's not a short term policy it
saying two elderly people you've retired
you've worked hard because of the
financial situation globally interest
rates are low so here's a way of putting
your savings to work to give
standard of living more childcare for
working families that's about helping
people who want to work more hours or go
back to work have that choice these are
long-term policies that we can afford to
do because the long-term plans working x
4's think it